can't push it push one push your ass
push around like where in Pete Davidson
gets cut from the latest episode of who
lose the Kardashians can push no can't
push it push your ass push your ass in
back in April Ripley's Believe It or Not
shared this clip of Kim Kardashian
trying on Marilyn Monroe's original
Happy Birthday Mr President dress at
their Orlando Florida location leading
up to the Met Gala what was the other
dress the one you said you don't like oh
yeah that one looked like a Halloween
party and Pete he was right by her side
do I need to put on another pair of
shapewear
I guess maybe that can
once it gets up it'll fit the back
no I don't think so you're good all
right sweet right I love that he's kind
yeah and really really thoughtful he's
the most thoughtful person and I love
the chemistry that Kim and him have
together it's really sweet I thought you
said the chemistry I was like okay
chemistry second chemistry well that
chemistry fizzled out and the two called
it quits a few months later in August
now on the latest episode of the famous
family's reality show fans get a behind
the scenes look at Kim's Journey to the
Met Ball including that trip to Florida
I have honestly been working my ass off
to see my vision come to life I will be
crushed if this doesn't pay off dear
Lord should we sing Hallelujah or
something
do I need to put on another pair of
shapewear but her ex yeah he got cropped
out of the footage
I'm trying on shapewear
we're in the Maryland room
of course the comedian didn't film with
Kim for season one of the Kardashians
but back in April Kim told variety she
wasn't opposed to it who are you texting
Ken does his name rhyme with feet
and it appears Pete wasn't opposed to it
either he even popped up in the season 2
teaser trailer babe yeah do you want to
shower with me really quick
and while Pete did kinda sort of make an
appearance on the show my grandmom says
she misses you hey Pete I miss you too
Kim said fans shouldn't expect to see a
lot of him when the camera's up for him
it's like a skit or a roll it's not what
he does I'm obviously gonna talk about
what goes on in my life
and
he's a part of that but I also respect
that this is like my job and this isn't
his job so it's like you might get a
glimpse here and there but it's just
it is what it is we're just glad
Ripley's was there to capture the then
couple and all that Met Ball prep
cuteness
no I don't think so you're good
and on that note I'll leave you with
this sweet but hilarious moment
my double hat off
all the cool kids it works and we want
to use this somewhere what
just if I want to post any behind the
scenes if you don't want oh you want me
to have a double hat
[Music]